welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition
and within the last hour we just had a
big announcement from rocksteady that a
suicide squad was suggested the game
is now in development since the studio
released arkham knight
they've kind of went a bit quiet but we
did hear rumors that
this game was being made now before we
get into this story
make sure you smash that like button if
you're hyped and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into this story
okay so this was something that actually
leaked a couple of weeks ago
and we reported on the story as being
one of the major things that would be
announced at dc fandom
eagle-eyed redditors had noticed that
warner brothers had been registering a
lot of domains
and amongst these was suicide squad
game.com and suicide squad killer
justice league.com
now we have this absolutely amazing
teaser poster
of superman with a target on the back of
his head i don't know if you know but
superman's bulletproof so that might not
work
but it is sort of teasing exactly what
the game's gonna be
the suicide squad don't play by the
rules and clearly they're gonna be
attacking people from behind
you know just to make the most of the
situation now a couple of years ago
dc actually released a justice league
versus the suicide squad graphic novel
and i definitely recommend that you pick
it up as it's one of the best in
basically all of rebirth it sort of
follows the pov of killer frost as she's
brought into the squad
and they face off against the league in
in what is a really really great run
definitely pick that up and if it's
anything to go by then this game
is gonna be just balls to the wall
action now there have been certain plot
synopsis floating about
and basically from what we've heard the
game's gonna sort of center around the
justice league discovering the existence
of the suicide squad
and coming to terms with that they were
of course teased at the end of batman
arkham origins
and this is sort of a continuation of
that story with this squad becoming more
and more prevalent
this government-sponsored black ops team
who have bombs in the back of their neck
and basically do what they want are
pretty much an opposite to the justice
league who
they go into stuff voluntarily and want
to do good no matter what
the squad on the other hand are kind of
forced into it and
and they only really do it in exchange
for time off their sentence
we don't know that much about it but
with it being a suicide squad game i
mean you can take it as a given that
harley quinn is gonna feature very
heavily in it
she was also a pretty big character in
the arkham trilogy
so you can guarantee that she's gonna
pop up here amanda walla of course will
be making an appearance as
she's the leader of the team and you
can't really have the suicide squad
without her dropping by
i actually think that deathstroke is
gonna be in it too as he was at the end
of arkham origins
and slowly they've sort of put the
pieces in place in order to set this up
now at the moment that's all we kind of
know about it and obviously there's
going to be a lot of speculation on the
game and
we're going to just be hearing rumors
for the next couple of years i think it
probably will take a long while to
develop
but i hope that with rocksteady being
out of the limelight for so long
they've been slowly working away on it
in the shadows now the suicide squad are
obviously a hot property at the moment
as james gunn is doing his own solo
movie and i can just see hype building
towards us massively
as not only are we getting a justice
league game but also a suicide squad one
and a suicide squad movie
kindness sucks for marvel that they
released this news on the day that
marvel's avengers gets its beta
but you know dc and marvel they like
going back and forth now obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on this
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
if you want something else to watch then
check out our breakdown of the news
story that catwoman is getting an hbo
mac show coming very very soon
don't forget that every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning the mcu infinity saga box set
is leave a like comment on the video and
subscribe with notifications on
if you want to support the channel from
as little as 99 cents then please click
the join button below
as you get access to early videos and
you know we just love the support
if you want to come chat just after the
video make sure you click on the discord
link in the description below
or follow us on twitter at heavyspoilers
if not then
thank you for sticking until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you